welcome back so
I'm really excited to start abrief video series
on the sparse identificationof nonlinear dynamics
or SINDy algorithm.
It'sbeen just about five years since we first
published this the first SINDy paper and so in
this video sequence i'm going to walk you through
what we've learned since then about how to
compute SINDy to learn models for complex
systems and walk through tons of applications
of how it's been used in the literature
So i'm going to start with a brief overview.
SINDy is a procedure of taking time series data
and extracting interpretable and generalizable
dynamical systems models that describe that data
And i'll talk about what i mean by interpretable
generalizable later but essentially you can think
of this as a machine learning algorithm that
extracts dynamical systems models from your timeseries data
and those dynamical systems models
could take the form of an ordinary differentialequation
"dx/dt = f(x)" or a partial
differential equation "u_t= somenonlinear function of u"
In this case "x" would be
the minimal state needed to describe your system
and "u" would be some kind of spatial temporal
field that's evolving in space and time so to
make this concrete let's say your data was from
this Lorenz system you know this chaotic kind
of mixing butterfly attractor... all you have is
time series data of a trajectory or an ensemble
of trajectories moving along this vector field
you would want to discover a dynamical system
of the form of the actual Lorenz equations.
So that's what SINDy does from time series data
out of all of the possible models that
could describe it it comes up with this
kind of sparse minimalistic model that
actually recapitulates the Lorentz model.
Similarly if I add a movie of flow past
a cylinder of fluid flow, I might want
to discover a partial differential equation like
the Navier-Stokes equations that kind of has the
minimal key ingredients needed to describe the
balance in this case of velocity and vorticity
in this field and this is kind of generally the
philosophy we're going to take: from this
data we don't just want *a* model that fits thatdata...
there's tons of machine learning algorithms
that will give you accurate long-term forecasts
of these dynamical systems but a lot of those are
kind of opaque or black box models we really put
a premium on getting equations dynamical systems
models that are sparse that have as few degrees
of freedom possible that describe the behavior
so that's kind of what we're looking for here and
this really rests on the idea that out of all of
the possible dynamical systems that could have
described this lorentz system or this fluid flow
these are actually quite simple the right
hand sides or these differential equations
only have a very few terms in the equations
the lorentz equations have seven terms
and likewise the Navier-Stokes equations are
quite simple out of all the possible differential
equation terms that could describe them these
are both relatively sparse so that's what we
mean by the sparse identification of nonlineardynamics.
And there's a third interpretation that
we'll talk about also which is even if i have a
spatial temporal system a high dimensional system
like this fluid flow i think when i simulate this
i need approximately a hundred thousand degrees
of freedom in the computer you can discover
a partial differential equation but you might
also want to represent this as a low dimensional
combination of a few basis modes so oftentimes you
can take these spatial temporal fields like
a fluid flow and decompose it into a few key
variables in this case this combination of three
modes with amplitudes x y and z and you can derive
a sparse differential equation model in terms of
those mode amplitudes and so this is a classic
model from the literature by barrett noak and
colleagues that we can discover using the cindy
algorithm purely from measurement data like this
okay that's the mile-high view of what cindy does
we introduced it in this pnas paper in 2016.
so this was work with josh proctor and nathan
kutz my my close colleagues and collaborators
where we kind of introduced this idea of trying
to learn a dynamical system with as sparse of
a representation as possible purely from data
and we have kind of this schematic overview of how
the algorithm works i'll walk you through this in
a minute but the idea is in the last five years
we've learned a ton about how to compute these
cindy models from data from noisy data from
high dimensional systems stochastic systems
and you know the capabilities of this have really
dramatically improved since this first paper so i
thought it would be fun to kind of you know make a
video five years later of everything we've learned
i get emails all the time of people you know
trying this out on their data to learn their
dynamical systems and so i want to give you in
this series of videos kind of insights into where
are the pitfalls how do you actually compute this
and use this as a tool for scientific discovery
good okay so uh in this kind of video series
what we're going to do is we're going to walk
through the big picture algorithm i'm going
to tell you kind of all of the key steps
that are involved in computing these models
from data so that we can get these interpretable
generalizable models i'm specifically going to
point out many of the common pitfalls that we
run into or challenges that we face when we
try to learn these models what kind of data
do you need what coordinate systems are good to
measure in how do you build the cindy library of
the candidate terms that you're selecting
from and what optimization algorithms are
most likely to give you kind of good physical
cindy models so this i think will be multiple
parts of the lecture series i'll have a whole a
whole video abstract on all of the cool sparse
non-linear fluids models that we've developed
in my group and with my close collaborators
over the last five years so this is just a
passion of mine i love modeling fluid flows and
cindy has turned out to be an extremely powerful
method of getting kind of low dimensional sparse
interpretable representations of lots of complex
systems from electro convection to turbulent wakes
fusion reactors and many more so this will be a
whole video i'm really excited to share with you
we'll talk more broadly about
the other applications of cindy
whether it's for modeling you know
chemical kinetics in the human body
plasma dynamics non-linear optic systems or
mechanical systems there's tons and tons of
applications of these sparse nonlinear modeling
uh procedure and in general i just want us to
be thinking you know there's so many dynamical
systems in the world that we're interested in
most of the world around us is changing
in time it's constantly changing
some of the systems like this double pendulum
i can write down the laws of physics you know
from first principles and get a pretty
good model i can use for control but
many other systems like the human brain or an
ecological system a disease modeling system
we don't have the governing equations and so these
kinds of automated model discovery techniques
can be really really powerful in those systems and
that's i hope what we do in the next five years
is really crack some of those big
big scientific discovery problems
okay good so that's what we're going to do
we're going to cover kind of the overview of the
algorithm major pitfalls and then get into some
key applications that kind of motivate how and
why you might use this and also set up some of the
problems that we might want to study in the future
and i'm going to walk through now an overview
of the cindy method but i want to motivate why
we want sparsity why do we care about
having minimalistic simplistic models
and you've heard me say this before i'm going
to say it again it's very important kind of
perspective in machine learning is that as we
start as we continue to design and develop and
discover models from data that's what machine
learning is as we discover our models from data
of dynamical systems we have to put a
premium on models that are interpretable
and generalizable if we ever want to have these
models be useful for safety critical control
systems for autopilots for autonomy for robotic
systems in the loop with humans then we need our
models to be interpretable we need to understand
what they mean and they need to generalize outside
of the training data where we train them instead
of defining these two uh words what i'm going to
do is give you an example so i think that the
ultimate interpretable and generalizable model
is newton's f equals ma so it's interpretable in
the sense that it has three terms f m and a and
we can write these down for a problem of interest
we can analyze explain interpret they have units
and it's generalizable in the sense that newton
can learn f equals ma from apples falling on
earth that's how the story goes and this law
f equals ma is still valid when we design
space missions to the moon that's the ultimate
generalizable model so i guarantee that you could
take movies of apples falling data from apple's
falling and you could train a deep neural network
to make new movies of apples falling or to predict
the motion of those apples but that deep neural
network is not going to be useful for space
mission design unless you take a big step back
and guarantee that you're enforcing interpretable
and generalizable models so that's what we want
we want models that are more like f equals ma
and less like these big opaque neural networks
and this is a principle in physical modeling
that's been around for for thousands of years
um from aristotle until now that the kind of
right physical model is typically the model
that is as simple as possible but no simpler and
that's a very elegant statement of this principle
of parsimony that you want the the sparsest the
simplest model possible but no sparser no simpler
and the way that we enforce this today
with mathematical tools is by getting
models that are low dimensional that vary that are
described by as few degrees of freedom as possible
and models that are sparse that have as few terms
in the dynamical system as are needed to describe
the observed dynamics and that's kind of the whole
philosophy behind this cindy algorithm is we want
sparse models in terms of a few variables
now if you fast forward um from newton
until the present computational era this starts
to look a lot like the lorentz 1963 model
so the lorentz 1963 model is describing this very
very rich turbulent chaotic convection that you
observe in the atmosphere and he does it in terms
of this very very simple three equation model so
it's in terms of a low dimensional state x y and
z which represent the mode amplitudes of three
important spatial modes and the dynamics of those
three variables are described in terms of a very
simple ordinary differential equation with seven
terms most of them linear a few of them quadratic
so again that's the kind of interpretable
and generalizable model that we would like
is something like this lorentz model so that's
how i'm going to illustrate the cindy approach
our sparse identification of nonlinear
dynamics algorithm is on this uh this
lorentz system and again this is joint
work with nathan kutz and josh proctor
we've you know had many many extensions to
this method together in the last five years
and this is the warm-up problem that we use to
explain cindy for the first time so we're going to
pretend that we have access only to data from the
laurent system we know that there are governing
equations but we don't know what they are we just
measure x y and z the state of the system in time
so every row is a measurement in time and we
assume that we can compute the derivatives x dot
y dot and z dot now that's a big assumption and
we're going to relax that assumption in a minute
but assume you have access to measurements of
the data in time now the simplest thing that you
could try would be to model this dynamical system
using a linear model or a best fit 3x3 a matrix
that best predicts the time derivatives from the
measurement of the state now and this is what
the dynamic mode decomposition or dmd would do is
essentially it would give you a best fit three by
three model that would best propagate that system
forward in time but we know that a three by three
linear model is not going to capture the rich
dynamics of this lorentz system a simple a matrix
has a single fixed point at the origin it can't
describe the multiple fixed points of the laurent
system the unstable periodic orbits or the uh the
rich chaotic dynamics that we observe so instead
what the cindy algorithm does is it augments the
right-hand side of possible model terms to include
nonlinear terms in addition to the state itself so
in this case for example in addition to x y and z
we add terms x squared x y y squared and all the
way up in this case to fifth order polynomials
so we augment our library to include more terms
that could be used to describe the left-hand side
the x dot the y-dot and the z-dot and notice that
all of these uh gray columns in this theta library
can be computed from the data that i measured in
x y and z if i have x i can compute x squared if
i have x and y i can compute x times y and
so on so this is a computable matrix and now
the entire objective of the cindy algorithm
is to try to find the fewest terms in this
library of candidate dynamics that describe the x
dot equation that describe the y dot measurements
and that describe the z dot measurements okay so
for example i'm trying to find the fewest columns
of theta that add up to equal x dot that add up
to equal y dot and then add up to equal z dot
now 20 years ago this would have been
a combinatorial brute force search
out of all possible sparse combinations of columns
to find the best fit to x dot y dot and z dot
now that's a commodity algorithm in optimization
there are dozens of sparse optimization algorithms
that will give you the sparsest subset of theta
that adds up to x dot y dot and z dot we have
our own favorite that i'll tell you about
later but there's lots of them like the lasso
hard thresholding and so on and so forth and
so when you do this sparse optimization in
this library you essentially learn the structure
of your dynamical system and the parameters of
what terms are active so you learn that the x dot
equation is linear in x and y which is actually
true in the lorentz equations the y dot equation
has a linear term in x and y and a nonlinear x
z term and the z dot equations have a z and an x
y term and in fact that is exactly what the true
lorentz equations are governed by and we learn
that purely from measurement data of our system
so this is something that is true in almost every
system we've looked at where we knew the answer is
that by imposing this sparsity condition by trying
to find the sparsest model possible that that
explains the observed data we tend to discover
the actual true dynamics that generated the
data in the first place and that's very promising
because if we can rediscover dynamics that we know
using the sparse algorithm then hopefully we can
discover new dynamical systems that we don't know
and still have them be interpretable and
generalizable like these models okay good now you
can do this for ordinary differential equations
like i've shown you i'm going to show you all of
the challenges later that you can run into in
did we measure the right variables is this the
right library what sparse optimization algorithm
do i employ all of those are real challenges that
we'll talk about in this video series and there's
open source code uh pi cindy you can download this
on github read about it on joss or on the archive
and try this out for yourself we want this to be
you know continually getting better because of
community involvement so so please try this out
you can also discover partial differential
equations so i alluded to that in the
intro if i have spatial temporal data for
example this fluid flow past a cylinder
if i measure the vorticity field omega
and the x and y velocity fields u and v
in space and time i can build a partial
differential equation model for this
so just like in cindy we build a regression
problem so this is a generalized linear problem
where we try to represent the time derivative of
some quantity in this case the time derivative of
vorticity as a sparse combination of a library
of candidate partial derivatives and nonlinear
products of partial derivatives so i compute all
of these these gray columns by computing partial
derivatives and nonlinear cross terms from
this data and i'm trying to find the sparsest
combination of these terms that add up to equal
the time derivative of omega my vorticity and when
we do this when we apply this sparse regression
we actually learn purely from data that the navy
or stokes equations are the dynamics that are
most consistent with the data and as sparse
as possible so this is fantastic work by sam rudy
who is a phd student working with nathan kutzenme
and he applied this to a ton of other systems i'll
show you in a minute what's cool is because when
you have this kind of spatial temporal data
there's so much data you can also massively
subsample little patches of that data in space and
time and even that sub-sampled problem is still
well conditioned enough oftentimes to learn
the true dynamics i'll point out that there
was a parallel paper by hayden shaffer who also
showed very shortly after the first cindy paper
that you could extend it to partial differential
equations so both of these papers kind of extend
cindy to learn pde systems and since then there
have been tons of cool applications learning
new models that have never been written down
before for plasma systems and many other systems
so sam also showed that if you have kind
of an ensemble of random walker data if you
have just like a random walk and you look at an
ensemble of these kind of uh these random walk
data and you look at the evolving distribution
of that random walker you can learn things like
the heat equation which describes kind of this
uh average motion of this diffusion in time of
these random walkers which we thought
was really cool so you can apply this
either in kind of the deterministic or in the
ensemble statistical framework to learn pdes
and he applied it in his first paper to many
many partial differential equations and again
in every case where we knew the answer by trying
to find the sparsest pde that described the data
we actually learned the correct dynamics uh you
know purely from measurement data so that was kind
of neat okay so i'm going to kind of wrap up this
video just by pointing out that there are some
big challenges and that's going to set up the
next few videos in this sequence so this is
the big picture kind of schematic overview of
cindy and there are a few key steps you need
to generate some data from a system you build a
library of candidate terms that could describe
those the dynamics of that data and
then you apply some sparse optimization
to uncover the the sparses combination are the
fewest dynamics terms needed to describe that data
and all of those have some real challenges
associated with them so the first challenge
is in the coordinates how did i know that x
y and z were the right variables to measure
that's not obvious at all if i'm measuring data
from a from the brain how do i know that what i'm
measuring are the right dynamic variables to that
admit a sparse dynamical system so that's a key
first challenge the second challenge is in the
library even if i measured the right variables how
do i know that my dynamics are polynomial how do
i know that they're quadratic in cubic and quartic
maybe their signs and cosines maybe they're
bessel's functions how do i design the library
so that i can get a dynamical system that's sparse
and accurate the third challenge and when we first
wrote this paper five years ago we thought that
this was kind of the hard challenge it turns out
this is maybe the easiest part is the optimization
what algorithms do i actually use to get a sparse
model once i have the right coordinates once i
have a good library how do i actually find the
sparsest combination that give me my dynamical
system and in this third challenge this is where
a lot of the kind of physics informed machine
learning comes in if i know partial physics can i
in enforce that in my optimization can i constrain
my optimization to give me sparse solutions
that are also physical by construction a
lot of interesting questions here as well
and then there's a zeroth challenge and we don't
always talk about this but this is super super
important which is the data itself cindy relies
on having high quality data pretty clean data
uh rapidly sampled in time and enough of it that
you can kind of disambiguate different types of
dynamical systems and get the right model
that describes your your system so there's
fundamental questions like how much data do i need
how fast do i have to sample it what quality how
little noise do i need and we're going to
talk about all of that in upcoming videos
so if you are interested in learning the real nuts
and bolts of how to do cindy for model discovery
in your system of interest i'm going to talk about
all of these challenges in the upcoming videos
and we're also going to talk about
key success stories in fluid dynamics
and in other fields so that you can get a feeling
of how to do this sparse modeling in your own
problem okay stay tuned we're going to talk
about all of this coming up soon thank you you